i don't want to pass people before and
they they laughing and i'm like what
y'all laughing at i'm sharp i look
good i look dead ass good how are you
what are you laughing at yo what's up
it's gunna and this is my style history
with
gq right here i was at my album release
for ds forever top is coma dagger song
blaze i bought out of max field the
under is just a white powder shirt i
wore some defensive like schlepps i was
slacks it wasn't like a set it wasn't a
suit and then i got the p head on and p
is me you know simply i'm a i'm a
walking p pushing p is is is what we're
doing we push p p itself is like it's
simply player but it's also it's
something that you're doing like say
like i came today and i'm doing an
interview with gq like that's pushing p
like gq been known for styling like and
i'm a style guy so it's just like y'all
standing on styles right now we pushing
pete to the fullest and it's like a
lifestyle now
is that a sticker on your glasses
yes i was already pushing p this day got
the dr top turtleneck got the rick going
vest up under black louis shorts and
then the shoes wrecked on high top
joints i'm saying the ones you can wear
with shorts it would semi viral people
like was like
kind of like trying to clown me and like
make jokes about the outfit i had on how
does it feel when you see these comments
about yours i'd be laughing at him too
it'd be funny like you took the time out
your day to do this you could have did
anything else better but your life you
had nothing else to do
two months later reread dressing like me
happy halloween and now everybody in the
world think this outfit is fire i guess
we had to let them know that we told you
about reposting the photo retold me when
we broke hit the internet that's when
i've not figured out already been in my
closet because the first she posted the
shoes
and she posted like the gunners and i'm
like she can't be talking about me one
of my friends like bruh she tell my shoe
now she hit me the shoes like the
gunners i like what you got going on is
you trying to be funny like everybody
else you feeling like you got jokes too
and then she posted a picture she posted
the whole the three pictures that long
list you know like i was on one yeah i
was on two
i think he okayed it because me and
rocky cool me and him be on the same
time like we just we p's we play us
every time i see him it's player time
this look was like get rid of their
heavy hair like i was buying and putting
stuff together a lot around that time i
remember where like i kind of started
getting money from music i had some
saint laurent pants it was like the
hardest thing in my pants to have it was
leather and they had zippers on them
like right by the knee top i can't
really remember but i had a nice
leather jacket to go on top of that i
remember getting those gucci shoes
though and just came out with like that
type of style i was really like on a lot
of gucci then i remember animal prints
on top of the gucci i had the crown
heart glasses on to cheetah print and we
got a young gunner with a fro too tell
me about the fro era i was that hungry
gonna like i eat anybody in the world
gonna write in the neck yeah this photo
is from 2018 it was a real big year for
me but i dropped drip harder and me and
baby i became like a worldwide star you
know this picture we performed at bt
awards dripped too hard i had a prada
shirt on with defending overalls stella
mccartney shoes got it on that with the
overalls it was very different
especially at the time it's my first bt
awards performance you know so i had to
set a tone and who's flying here you
were a baby baby looked good though he
got he got the chanel vests on [ __ ] in
there sneakers you know it's cool but i
still won like even like around this
time i remember well like we did a photo
shoot and we had the same pants on
without even
trying like but it was a mirror snake
pants i was buying a lot of cartiers
then my hand is to get i was
diamond cardi yes had a tennis change
here where i only wanted 10 exchange
who's the king of drip me and did you
coin the word drip night drip came from
me trying to use another word
instead of swag because we used to be
swag
and used to have played too you seem to
say swaver like swag and flavor
like you had to know
if you know you know like you had been
from atlanta to know like slavery and
like futuristic like black by white but
sweat and then started to just drip like
now we're dripping i was spilling like
it just it was another error from
instead of sweat i was in paris 2019 was
this your first paris fashion week yes
it was i did a fashion show for
casablanca it was a casablanca jumpsuit
peach peacock please then i had red
bottoms on all white red bottoms comfy
was that your first time walking for a
runway show yeah i mean he he reached
out while while i was down there you
know and i was familiar with the brand
already so like when he reached out like
yo see if conor would be interested i
definitely was interested i pulled up on
him the day before the show was to kind
of just get everything fitted and
situated this photo is for louisville
time virgin just me god bless the dead
they sent me maybe like two or three
jackets and then like two three
different pants and a pair of shoes to
kind of like pick like if you want to
wear this one i just i like what they
gave me
all of those pieces it's a louis vuitton
trench jacket like rain coat blue and
purple then i got a purple louis vuitton
bucket on everything else is just all
white white when you're looking for a
hat what kind of catches your eye i'm
looking for a hat it got to either
caught my attention or i know it's going
to go with something ain't really too
tough don't just buy a hat just because
i see it
this look for speed tier was 2019 the
outfit itself is rigged on the jacket
the pan the shoes are proper the glasses
ring awesome this outfit really wasn't
about the outfit it was about the birkin
me just coming out with that big 50
letting people know like i'm in that bag
that broken bag also dropped the video
for baby berkey were all of those
birkins in the video of yours yeah was
like half and half some of them was
purchased and some of them was rented
and the one that was purchased i kind of
gave them out to like special people
would you say you started a birkin trend
in hip-hop i would say i brought it back
i didn't start it it was already a thing
but like for my generation i brought it
back especially like for a man because
you don't really see men in a big
parking
50 cm bag like they ain't even just two
trillion just knowing like you know what
i'm saying so
i for sure was created at it
this picture is a party for youtube it
was an atlanta i had on a stella
mccartney outfit on top of it was a
mason margiela peacock pancho type how
did growing up in atlanta impact your
style atlanta breed diamonds you know
like we create is where i get like a lot
of my inspiration from this look i also
did louis vuitton fashion show from
virgin past you won't see like anybody
in it it's a statement piece to me i got
a louis vuitton poncho louis vuitton
khaki shorts green louis vuitton socks
the bag in my hand is like it's the
shape of a cup but it's also a bag too i
just had maybe like the snack candy in
there what kind of impact did virgil
have on your stower it's a lot of stuff
that he made that was like future people
wouldn't know why he's fired right now
but tom would they know he's the future
like he was seeing stuff before it came
tell me about this look in one word
queen elizabeth
they told me that queen elizabeth was
going by this jacket but she hadn't made
it up there yet to miami so
i said i get it i'll take it you know
i'm saying i'm very fond of queen
elizabeth i take it the pants was
swayed saint laurent in the shoes was
morning loafers i'm saying wrong this
video me
do this outfit came from ash lorenzo at
my shoes of levine yeah i had it on this
day too and you and thug what were the
conversations around styling for the
video we always just go like yin yang
but it's a different color like play off
that with videos just so it won't look
techy
i'm performing at wireless london my
mama back there somewhere on the stage
kron hart pain just came out that day in
london i pushed peter that sure and the
pants probably resell right now maybe
like 7 800 i ain't even know where nip
hit it shirt was spider the vest is
spider the bucket spider thug
the jacket actually came from a girl
from new york she she live out here very
strong hanging out at the bottom
yeah
but see this was a default though i had
to wear them by by force not choice i
wanted white out first ones but i
couldn't find them they didn't have many
more sizes
in london so i had to wear these pulled
it off this day i did something very
very special i went to my junior high
school i opened a grocery store for a
kid who parents like you know got a hard
time and can't always afford certain
things sometimes food
and toiletries and different clothing
just freedom all free that's pushing pee
right there like when you get back
and you stand on it and you do it from
the heart let's push p the shoes are
mcqueen the socks are capital elite top
the black dickey shorts what kind of
makes you wear shorts or pictures for
enough teddy trying to show off my
tattoos that's the only reason why i'm
wearing shorts just like so you can just
see you just see all my tattoos
this bit has been copied by basketball
players this bit has been copied by
football players this fit has been
copied by rappers and how do you feel
about that i feel absolutely fine
but don't laugh and don't act like i
can't drip god i don't go in front of
your comments and say hey you look like
me you know what i'm saying
just when you see me in my office i'm
just liking because you know you might
want to try another day you know what
i'm saying each other like i ain't do it
describe this for me in one word trippy
drippy i got it on i still don't see
nobody buy this outfit i ordered it from
overseas i was like one of the first to
be helped to the man marine it's a
woman's
brand that they had means also someone i
popped out with it was it was like damn
we didn't even know man had that look
you know it's a statement this is the
fit the jacket the boots the hat that's
all virgil over time and it's version
nico and all the time it was my brother
mark's birthday that day i just stepped
that i had to put it on the boots master
jackie got a duck on
brown leather pants cut the jury my
shady baby piece on this but i got it on
a different cube and this is shorter i
went shorter that day my wife penned it
um
where exactly what you want to wear you
can't dress like me i don't mind but do
what you like you know like make sure
you put your twists on to put your touch
on it and style you won't and when
somebody talk about you try to give you
this credit for the outfit don't take it
personal because they might not know
style you know they might not know i
don't want to pass people before and
they laughing and i'm like what y'all
laughing at i'm sharp i look
good i look dead ass good how you what
are you laughing at
so it'd be it'd be those type of people
you know so
i would tell you don't worry about it
just just keep dripping